[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute messbar
hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch katja stresow
für den sport
und das sind die wichtigsten nachrichten
themen von heute
ersatz für russisches öl und gas die usa
wollen riesige mengen flüssiggas nach
deutschland und in andere staaten
liefern
weiter flucht aus dem kriegsgebiet immer
mehr ukraine verlassen ihre heimat in
richtung westen trotz kleiner
militärische erfolge
und italien muss zu hause bleiben mit
der 0 1-niederlage gegen nord mazedonien
verpasst der fußball-europameister die
wm-teilnahme
das leid in der ukraine ist schwer
auszuhalten und lässt die forderungen
nach einem sofortigen energie im bau
gegen russland immer lauter werden doch
einige eu mitglieder wie deutschland
lehnen das weiter ab die usa wollen der
eu künftig riesige mengen flüssigkeiten
flüssiggas liefern trotzdem werde
deutschland noch mindestens zwei jahre
von russischem gas abhängig sein sagt
das wirtschaftsministerium bei öl und
kohle ging es schneller in arbeit es hat
mir
der wirtschaftsminister mit guten
nachrichten erste erfolge seien erzielt
so sagt er um unabhängiger zu werden von
energie aus russland wir sind ja im
regelmäßigen gespräch mit den
unternehmen so dass ich denke dass wir
im frühsommer die abhängigkeit von kohle
aus russland weitestgehend reduziert
haben bei erwarte ich eine halbierung
selbst auf russisches gas könne man in
einem kraftakt in zwei jahren vielleicht
schon verzichten ein weiterer schritt
weg von putin heute auch am rande des
eu-gipfels joe biden verspricht künftig
mehr flüssiggas in die eu zu liefern als
geplant
ich weiß der abschied von russischem gas
heißt mehrkosten für europa aber der
schritt ist nicht nur moralisch richtig
erstarkte auch unsere gemeinsame basis
denn auch am tag zwei des brüsseler
gipfels ist klar russland wird weiter
hunderte millionen euro pro tag für in
die kassieren es gibt keine mehrheit für
ein embargo allen voran die deutschen
wollen das nicht für alle aber ist die
unabhängigkeit ein langfristiges ziel we
want also wir europäer wollen
diversifizieren weg von russland hin zu
lieferanten die unsere freunde sind und
denen wir trauern können
bleibt das problem der hohen preise die
kommission schlägt vor künftig mehr gas
vorräte anzulegen und energie gemeinsam
und damit preiswerter einzukaufen so
stunde ringen die staats und
regierungschefinnen immer noch um
lösungen am ende beschleunigt der krieg
das längst überfällige eine neue
energiepolitik
russland will offenbar sein vorgehen in
der ukraine ändern die ukrainischen
kräfte seien in bedeutendem umfang
reduziert worden meldet das russische
verteidigungsministerium
damit können die armee als hauptziel die
befreiung des don was in angriff nehmen
die ukrainische seite dagegen berichtet
von rück eroberungen von stetten vor
tobias häfner und axel konrad
herzen für den opa auf einem bahnsteig
in kiew er will das nötigste der familie
hüten so lange es geht bis seine tochter
mit den enkeln zurückkehren kann
mir blutet das herz aber es ist meine
oberste pflicht meine kinder zu schützen
wenn wir den krieg gewonnen haben will
ich heimkehren doch vorerst bleibt die
familie getrennt
auch in der umkämpften kleinstadt in der
nähe glauben viele trotz der zerstörung
weiter fest an einen ukrainischen erfolg
diese kämpfer heißt es von seiten der
ukraine seien oft nicht mehr nur im
verteidigungs- modus sondern wollten
versuchen die russen aktiv
zurückzudrängen pläne erörtern im
untergrund und dann aber in den bus der
sie nach eigenen angaben direkt ins
kampfgebiet bringt
mein sohn ist 18 monate alt ich werde
wohl töten um seine zukunft zu sichern
materialprobleme und verlustreicher
häuserkampf davon will man im russischen
staatsfernsehen nichts wissen bis ins
hinterste dorf sollen die bilder
signalisieren technisch überlegen
erfolgreich bestens versorgt bis hin zum
militärseelsorger heute eine neue zahl
aus dem kreml bisher
1351 tote russische soldaten ein wert
den experten für geschönt halten und
eine überraschende ankündigung aus dem
verteidigungsministerium in moskau die
eroberung der donbass regionen der ost
ukraine nach kreml deutung befreiung
genannt sei nun der primäre fokus der
russischen truppen
mario pohl im süden aus der stadt der
ruinen kommt die nachricht dass am 16
märz bis zu 300 menschen im zerstörten
theater gestorben sein sollen
überprüfbar ist das derzeit nicht
ganz im westen lemberg hier können tote
auch aus anderen landesteilen noch in
würde beerdigt werden und die
angehörigen erleben kurz stille im land
des krieges
[Musik]
us-präsident beiden demonstriert auf
seiner europareise weiter den
schulterschluss mit den verbündeten
nach den treffen in brüssel ging es
weiter zur ostflanke der nato nach polen
in einen ort 90 kilometer entfernt von
der ukrainischen grenze natalie steger
sein besuch beginnt mit einer
schrecksekunde auf polnischer seite der
us präsident wird im südost polnischen
rzeszów nur vom verteidigungsminister
polens begrüßt präsident da hatte
notlanden müssen wegen eines technischen
defekts besuch bei us soldaten wegen der
ukraine krise hat washington sein
kontingent in polen verdoppelt
ihre generation steht an einem
wendepunkt
die frage ist wer wird herrschen
demokratien und die werte die wir teilen
oder autokratien
biden will ein zeichen setzen die gut
9.000 us soldaten in polen stehen für
die solidarität der usa denn seit dem
russischen angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
geht gerade im polnischen grenzgebiet
die sorge um dass man ebenfalls ziel
sein könnte
wenn wir mehr soldaten bei uns hätten
würden wir uns sicherer fühlen im falle
eines angriffs von
der us-regierung erwarte ich dass sie
garant für ruhe hier in diesem
landesteil ist
gemeinsames briefing schließlich mit
polens präsident mit hilfsorganisationen
nach polen sind die meisten ukraine
geflohen mehr als zwei millionen morgen
finden die offiziellen bilateralen
gespräch in warschau statt polen hätte
gerne eine ständige us-militärbasis mit
bis zu 40.000 soldaten so eine zusage
von beiden ist unrealistisch gilt dies
doch bei westlichen nato partnern als
potenzielle provokation moskaus
das erschrecken über russlands krieg in
der ukraine hat auswirkungen bis hinein
in die arktis so sagte es heute
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg die
region um den nordpol sei von
strategischer bedeutung für europas
sicherheit ein lange geplantes
nato-manöver in nordnorwegen soll
verteidigungsbereitschaft signalisieren
florian a
wenn es ernst wird lassen sich panzer
der nato durch ein paar pannen nicht
stoppen und hier ist es ernst so ernst
wie eine übung nur werden kann die nato
trainiert in nordnorwegen und sieht das
land verteidigen würde geografisch ist
der ukraine krieg zwar weit weg gefühlt
plötzlich ganz nah ist seriös es ist
ernsthafter als sonst man denkt mehr an
die konsequenzen der arbeit und warum
wir das machen das training wird dadurch
realistischer
wie kommen sie mal wieder lästig
30.000 soldaten aus 27 ländern es ist
eines der größten nato manöver seit
jahren und zugleich ein balance-akt
stärke demonstrieren ohne zu provozieren
in einem konflikt in dem sich auch hier
jeder fragt wie real ist die bedrohung
wirklich mit erstaunen verfolgt man mal
der nato wie sehr der russische angriff
auf die ukraine ins stocken geraten ist
kaum jemand glaubt dass das land darüber
hinaus in der lage wäre einen nato-staat
anzugreifen nur ausschließen lässt sich
das nicht lieber vorsorgen und
abschrecken das ist sein motto
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg heute
in norwegen mit einem appell
um sicherzustellen dass unsere truppen
aus den verschiedenen ländern
zusammenarbeiten und bedrohungen aus
allen richtungen bekämpfen können dafür
brauchen wir mehr solcher übungen
man habe russland schon vor monaten
eingeladen das manöver in norwegen zu
beobachten sagt die nato russland aber
die einladung ausgeschlagen
der krieg in der ukraine belastet auch
das geschäftsklima in deutschland das
zeigt der aktuelle ifo index de ist im
vergleich zum februar von 98,5 auf 90,8
punkte gesunken grund sei ein
historischer einbruch der erwartungen
unter den rund 9000 befragten managern
die lebensmittelversorgung in europa und
deutschland sei trotz krieg weiter
gesichert sagt der bauernverband
hamsterkäufe seien unsinnig aber vieles
werde teurer vor allem brot denn
russland und die ukraine sind wichtige
kornkammern die jetzt nicht mehr liefern
russlands anteil am globalen
weizenexport lag zuletzt bei fast 20
prozent
der anteil der ukraine bei 8,5 prozent
damit fehlt fast ein drittel des in der
welt benötigten weizens hannah
hebestreit über die folgen
seines brot und leckerer kuchen beides
gebacken mit besten zutaten das könnte
schon bald deutlich teurer werden denn
der krieg in der ukraine bläht die
preise auf briefe den teich was wir
sehen sind natürlich immense
preissteigerungen am weltmarkt für
weizen und auch sonnenblumen
sonnenblumenöl sonnenblumenkerne das
macht sich schon bemerkbar teilweise mit
preissteigerungen bis zu 30 prozent und
mehr
verbraucher erleben die aktuelle preis
explosion vor allem an der tankstelle
einen aber das ist auch in den
ladenkassen teurer wird bei den
lebensmitteln muss ich sagen das wird es
mir noch nicht so stark auf aber ich
glaube es kommt noch pro zehn euro
möchte ich nicht bezahlen das sage ich
ganz ehrlich aber wenn es denn so ist
sich mal was ich tun
viele geschäfte rationieren schon die
abgabe von öl mehl oder nudeln um
weitere hamsterkäufe zu verhindern dabei
ist die versorgung in deutschland
sichergestellte wir stehen nicht vor
lebensmittelengpässen in europa und in
deutschland es muss hier keine panik
geschürt werden und niemand muss angst
haben dass wir uns nicht versorgen
können
aber die lebensmittel erzeugt seinen
selbst mehr für ihren sprit für saatgut
und dünger das treibt die preise und die
müssen auch weiter steigende mit die
produktion aufrecht erhalten bleiben
kann der ukraine krieg wird die preise
treiben aber wohl nicht auf zehn euro
pro brot wenn die rohstoffkosten liegen
dem bäckerhandwerk bei maximal 25
prozent
kostenlos den nahverkehr nutzen eine
gratis monatskarte das schlagen die
verkehrsminister der bundesländer vor
anstelle der neuen euro monatskarte die
die bundesregierung gestern beschlossen
hat der verwaltungsaufwand für die
verkehrsverbände sei so geringer nun
soll eine bund länder gruppe den
vorschlag prüfen die monatskarte soll es
drei monate lang geben als entlastung
von hohen energiepreisen
jetzt zu corona da geht der
gesundheitsminister davon aus dass die
infektionszahlen eigentlich doppelt so
hoch sind wie die offiziell gemeldeten
und schon die sind derzeit höher denn je
fast
296.000 500 neuinfektionen
registrierte das robert koch institut
innerhalb eines tages dazu
288 todesfälle die sieben tage incident
auf 1700
56,4 weil aktuell so viele beschäftigte
ausfallen kommen betriebe an ihre
grenzen aus thüringen daniela sonntag
der busby kommt nicht mehr vorübergehend
im thüringischen saalfeld musste der
regionale nahverkehrsbetrieb eine linie
komplett streichen es fehlen die fahrer
krone bedingt so viele fahrer ausfälle
die verleger nicht mehr kompensieren
können von 260 bus vorm 60 erkrankt
davon 35 bis 40 corona geht leid und
schmerz mehrere krankenkassen so auch
die bahn melden höchststände bei den
krankschreibungen in den arztpraxen
lange schlangen wie hier bei einer
infektion sprechstunden in erfurt das
ist in einem ausmaß wie wir das seit
beginn der korona pandemie noch nie
hatten der bundesgesundheitsminister
appelliert heute noch mal an die länder
die hotspot regelungen anzuwenden und
ruft dazu auf den zweiten booster auch
zu nutzen wir müssen
offensiver mit der vierten impfung
umgehen 90 prozent derjenigen die die
stiko die vierte impfung empfiehlt sind
noch mit der vierten impfung nicht geben
an vielen stellen wird der hohe
krankenstand kritisch doppelschichten
überstunden drk pflegedienstleiterin
yvonne lippert aus saalfeld macht gerade
drei jobs gleichzeitig ist nicht nur dem
zu schulden dass die mitarbeiter selber
betroffen sind sondern auch dass viele
kindergärten geschlossen sind oder
schulen und die mitarbeiter ihre kinder
zu hause betreuen müssen beim
nahverkehrsbetrieb in saalfeld fahren
mittlerweile alle die den
busführerschein haben vom chef bis zum
schlosser nach ostern hoffen sie kann
linie b wieder bedient werden
die eu will die macht von internet
giganten wie google oder facebook
einschränken mit strengeren regeln für
die konzerne und erweiterten rechten für
die user so werden die ganz großen der
branche gezwungen mit kleineren
konkurrenten zusammenzuarbeiten
bei messenger diensten soll die
kommunikation über verschiedene anbieter
hinweg möglich sein werden regeln
verletzt sind strafen in milliardenhöhe
vorgesehen
der sonntag wird politisch spannend das
saarland wählt und die zeichen stehen
auf machtwechsel im aktuellen
zdf-politbarometer kommt die regierende
cdu dort auf 28 prozent mit 41 prozent
liegt die spd deutlich davor fast alle
übrigen parteien kämpfen in der umfrage
mit der fünf-prozent-hürde und damit um
den einzug ins saarbrücker parlament
susanne freitag
endspurt mit self ihr herz echte
saarland liebe das motto glaubt man den
umfragen hat anke rehlinger bis jetzt
auf die richtigen themen gesetzt sie
will im saarland an die spitze das thema
arbeitsplätze das will ich zur chefsache
machen wenn mir die saarländerinnen und
saarländer das vertrauen schenken und
ein starkes regierungsmandat geben und
ich dieses thema dann aus der
staatskanzlei mit noch mehr wucht auch
nach vorne bringen kann sein corona test
war heute negativ tobias hans ist zurück
aus der quarantäne
umfragewerte tief motivation hoch wir
sehen das in allen umfragen auch
deutlich wird dass wir rund 40% menschen
haben die sich noch nicht entschieden
haben ob und wen sie wählen und das
bedeutet der der mobilisiert am besten
mobilisiert der wird am ende die nase
vorn habe in den umfragen liegt die afd
auf platz drei mit nur 6,5 prozent dabei
ist sie total zerstritten hat keinen
spitzenkandidaten in den landtag kommt
sie vermutlich trotzdem in der partei
muss sich ändern dass wir uns
konzentrieren auf politik und mich auch
streitigkeiten um rechtlich können auch
die grünen hatten sich zuletzt sehr
liegt heute ist besuch aus berlin damit
nouripour unterstützt im wahlkampf damit
die partei nicht an der
fünf-prozent-hürde scheitert das brot
vielen kleinen parteien
im landtag brauchst eine ökologische
stimme und wir brauchen unbedingt mehr
klimaschutz im saarland wir haben nur 20
prozent erneuerbare auch für die
wirtschaft wichtig zehn jahre lang war
die fdp nicht mehr im saar-landtag auch
ihr einzug noch ungewiss die leute haben
wirklich diese große koalition die sich
mit sich selbst zufrieden dieses land
regiert das haben die leute
nachdem oskar lafontaine die linke an
der saar verlassen hat droht ihr der
absturz in die bedeutungslosigkeit mich
stört das sehr dass es nur noch
diskutiert wird wer hat den hut auf in
der neuen großen koalition das wollen
wir verhindern und da gehen wir rein in
diese ecke für die kleinen parteien geht
es bei dieser wahl ums überleben an der
spitze des landes könnte es nach über 20
jahren zu einem machtwechsel kommen
fridays for future rief heute weltweit
zum klima streik auf allein in
deutschland gab es aktionen in mehr als
300 städten wie hier in hamburg die
protestierenden forderten schnell aus
den fossilen energien auszusteigen sie
verlangten zudem ein ende des krieges
und einen importstopp von öl kohle und
gas aus russland
jetzt zum fußball und einer dicken
überraschung in der wm-qualifikation
faustdick denn italien fährt nicht zur
fußball weltmeisterschaft ende des
jahres nach katar gestern verspielte der
aktuelle europameister die letzte chance
auf die wm durch ein blamables 0 zu 1
gegen den fußballzwerg nord mazedonien
die ehrwürdigen gemäuer auf roms piazza
cup annika haben schon deutlich
schlimmeres erlebt aber das sportliche
italien wirkt in den grundfesten
erschüttert von einem welt desaster ist
die rede zur hölle das peinliche aus nur
acht monate nach dem em titel emotionen
enttäuschung unfassbar italien verliert
die lage ist ernst das zweite mal
nacheinander keine wm für uns das ist
in der nachspielzeit nimmt italiens
unheil seinen lauf in gestalt von
alexander tschaikowsky der einstige
palermo profi trifft für nord mazedonien
mancinis 11 düpiert die außenseite ein
ungläubiger partylaune in palermo und in
der hauptstadt skopje nord mazedonien
fehlt nur noch ein volltreffer gegen
portugal zum wm-ticket dass italiens
europameister kläglich verpassen
deutschland ist ja bereits qualifiziert
und trifft morgen abend im ersten
testspiel des jahres auf israel das
ganze in sinsheim zu sehen live im zdf
von 20 uhr 15 dabei wird es einen
torwart-wechsel und eine premiere geben
sein debüt feiern wird der freiburger
nico schlotterbeck dem flick in der
innenverteidigung eine einsatzgarantie
gibt das wm casting ist eröffnet nach
den jüngsten eindrücken hat rückkehrer
julian weigel gute chancen den fehlenden
kimmig im mittelfeld zu ersetzen für
manuel neuer werden seine vertreter
trapp und test legen für jeweils eine
halbzeit im tor stehen das match eine
mischung aus ausprobieren und einspielen
auf
dieses spiel und am ende dann einen
guten start in das wichtige 2022 haben
alle verfügbaren spieler waren am abend
dabei nach vielen absagen weil eine gute
nachricht für den dfb trainer
und nochmal zum wintersport skispringer
karl geiger muss den gesamtweltcup sieg
wohl abhaken beim vorletzten einzel
wettkampf der saison beim skifliegen in
planica slowenien wurde geiger nur
zwölfter sein stärkster konkurrent der
japaner ryo kobayashi landete auf rang 5
und führt jetzt mit nahezu uneinholbaren
89 punkten es dominierten heute die
slowenen auf heimischer schanze mit den
plätzen eins zwei drei und vier das ist
mal was anderes
zum schluss noch ein geburtstagsgruß
[Musik]
elton john wird heute 75 jahre alt der
paradiesvogel des kennt die höhen und
tiefen des lebens er überwand drogen und
alkoholsucht und schenkte uns einige der
schönsten songs der welt bis heute
[Musik]
morgen kommen von norden wolken
ansonsten bleibt es sonnig und warum
details hat gleich katja und christian
sievers begrüßt hier um 10 im heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse
ein schönes wochenende wünschen wir
ihnen und bis morgen wenn sie mögen doch
wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt ein bisschen
bewegung ins wetter denn das hoch peter
bekommt konkurrenz durch das tief helmke
das bringt seine kaltfront morgen ins
spiel wobei die kalte luft im
wesentlichen östlich der deutschen
grenzen südwärts zieht aber die
kaltfront bemerken wir schon heute nacht
mit hohen wolken hier in schleswig
holstein oder auch im nördlichen
mecklenburg vorpommern bei einem recht
kräftigen wind aus west nordwestlichen
richtungen dazu ist es meist klar und
die temperaturen sinken auf plus 6 bis
minus 3 grad und klettern morgen meist
auf 16 bis 21 grad im norden bleibt es
bei 11 bis 15 grad kälter das liegt an
der kaltfront und den dichteren wolken
hier nordöstlich von weser und elbe es
ist nicht völlig ausgeschlossen dass es
hier im nördlichen brandenburg oder auch
in niedersachsen mal für ein paar
spritzer regen reicht südlich der
nördlichen mittelgebirge dagegen strahlt
die sonne und an diesem wetter ändert
sich auch am sonntag und am montag ganz
wenig am dienstag dann aber könnte es
tatsächlich für etwas nass von oben
reichen binnenschifffahrt und
landwirtschaft wird das freuen jeder
tropfen ist willkommen guten abend